ich muss mir manchmal sage ich einfach
wichtig finde ich wieder also ohne wenn
ich also wieder so starkes rennen und
einem zug zu düsen
nur so viel sie mit dem alter das wetter
sei aber das muss man selber machen und
helfenstein hat etwas gemacht
sie hat sich immer wieder neue ziele
gesetzt neue träume gelebt
wie schafft man es im hohen alter nicht
in lethargie zu versenken und wie trotzt
man lustvoll der eigenen vergänglichkeit
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
auf der zielgeraden ihres lebens wie das
root helfenstein noch einmal wissen
andere in ihrem alter sitzen vor dem
fernseher oder im café trend
sie trainiert für die leichtathletik
weltmeisterschaften
sie trainiert hart ausgerechnet sie die
bis zu ihrem 58
lebensjahr mitlaufen nichts am hut hatte
sie die ein klima war und zu dick wie
sie sagt und höchstens ab und an ein
paar bahnen geschwommen ist
roth helfenstein die vor acht jahren am
herzen operiert wurde steht mit 80
jahren vor der möglicherweise größten
erfolg ihres lebens helfenstein bietet
mir das du an
das sei in sportkreisen üblich so hat
das heißt inzwischen acht stunden oder
noch zwei monate bis zu den senioren
weltmeisterschaften wo sie gleich in
sieben laufdisziplinen an den start
gehen wird
ein besonderes augenmerk legt die
mittel- und langstrecken spezialistin
bei ihrem täglichen training auf den 60
meter sprint da soll die konkurrenz
besonders groß sein
fertig los
seit 50 jahren wohnt ruth den muttenz in
derselben eineinhalb zimmer wohnung
geheiratet hat sie nie der richtige sei
eben nie gekommen sagt die ehemalige
hauswirtschaftslehrerin aber die späte
liebe zum sport hat trotzdem mit einem
mann zu tun
doch dazu später im laufsport fühlte sie
sich die letzten 22 jahre aufgehoben wie
in einer familie einer weltumspannenden
großen familie
also in mehrere arten zum beispiel in
nordamerika
denn in südafrika da hat der marathon
club mit der besten zeit in durban auch
im osten in china und dabei vor allem in
europa fast alle größeren europäische
städte innerhalb von vom laufen erklärt
und die freundschaften die sind schon so
lang und die wartet also immer bist du
so lange ich glaube das hat mir so viel
braucht
am ersten april 2012 ist es soweit
auf geht's nach finnland hotel von stein
unterwegs mit ihrer um ein jahr älteren
schwester lidia frei auch sie eine
spätberufene video wurde erst vor fünf
jahren mit dem laufen los infiziert nach
dem tod ihres mannes
hier geht es weniger um
hundertstelsekunden und medaillen als um
schöne reisen an unbekannte orte
wie zum beispiel westen eine kleinstadt
vier stunden nördlich von helsinki
im verschlafenen städtchen treffen sich
anfang april 3000 athletinnen und
athleten zu den offiziellen hallen
leichtathletik weltmeisterschaften der
senioren
hier kämpfen die nächsten sechs tage
leichtathleten aus der ganzen welt um
ruhm und ehre
die jüngsten sind 35 die ältesten 93
immer fünf jahrgänge treten
gegeneinander an
[Musik]
dazu kommen eine zweite tross der
russischen bauern und das nur dass sie
nicht abstürzen und vorne vorne dann
haben sie oft das ist höher geworden und
einem baggerfahrer sag mal auf der
höchste baum gehört aber sind die hier
berichtet wird
so macht keine markiert im botanischen
garten david tennant und bin ich sogar
alex wochen ob sie im ganzen zu sechs
kilometern common sense media pack dann
doch der gründer
auch sevilla schließlich eine gute figur
machen
dollar
da habe ich also nicht ganz
da wäre mir
und 20
und die heißt
nein das bringt dich du ja recht
überhaupt aussagt nach stalin ehrlich
gesagt aus welt kopf machen kann sehr
schnell nicht unter fünf tagen
wir verstehen uns gut aber sie sind
kritisiert genauso
natürlich
richtig nichts
es ist diese welt in der hut aufblüht
doch ganz gut so die diebe halterungen
an die ganze abfahrer und setzte aber am
wetter und so noch der alles punkten
einfach die politische kontakte zum teil
zerstört das ist so aber das wetter
ausgerechnet morgen findet der einzige
wettkampf draußen statt
doch die schwestern sind gut vorbereitet
sie haben eisen für die schuhe im gepäck
im heinz schrieb wir sind gut das ist
alles und das ist langsam zwei monate
früher ins spiel
hier wohnt 1 bar niemand der mann der
roots liebe zum laufsport geweckt hat
[Musik]
mut und heinz haben sich anfang der 80er
jahre kennengelernt
einst arbeitete damals als polizist in
basel
nach dem tod seiner frau sind die beiden
näher zusammengerückt der 89 jährige war
in früheren jahren ein begeisterter
sportler mit ski und schwimmlehrer
patent
[Musik]
ja ich kenne jede vom frühjahr sicher
aus rümpel und welche mit sexy und den
kann ich das mache du machst ja gar
nicht dass der schwindel und so es ist
ja doch einmal die frage ob das hätte
sein programm in zehn wochen am
frauenlauf wenn ich das mal mit mal
ungeschlagen
minute rennen das schlagen und haben
aber nach dem programm aber trainieren
also klammheimlich übrigens an
sekundenschlaf und hektisch sagte ob es
machbar walter lich aussagen dazu welche
voran trainiert hat sich leicht und habe
sich ausmachen
und wenn es möglich sei naja verlängern
und zwar bloss um resultate sondern
unser stil und umfeld für st
und der ist sofort ich stecke und
[Musik]
in finnland schneit es seit 24 stunden
ununterbrochen am frühen morgen im
hotelzimmer der helfenstein schwestern
[Musik]
also so haben es nicht vorstellen das
sind 20 zentimetern ab so einfach du
bist größten tja das wetter muss ja
einfach so dass ich zum trost analytical
ihrer beweglichen rechte reaktiv werden
fordert fischer gesunken
gestern begann in china gab keine insel
und nur wenig spazieren
ich freue mich schon auf morgen
wir bereiten sich die frauen über 55
jahre auf den cross vor
jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr nicht für
die beiden schweizerinnen andere aus der
kategorie der über 80 jährigen ließen
sich vom schnee und minustemperaturen
abschrecken
rhodia sind ohne konkurrenz
[Musik]
also wenn ihr unsere stumpf
ja unsere richtung eine so gesund
für dich zu sehen
[Musik]
beim start scheint immerhin die sonne
aber es ist bitterkalt
[Musik]
roth legt ein flottes tempo vor und
überholt bereits jüngere
lydias einziges ziel ankommen
[Musik]
mit
mut verpasst ihr ziel knapp unter einer
stunde einzulaufen
aber sie ist weltmeisterin
[Musik]
20 minuten später die männer bereiten
sich schon auf ihren lauf vor schafft es
auch lydia
[Musik]
doppelsieg brot und lidia in deren
elternhaus wie sie sagen unkraut jäten
der einzige gesperrt war
bohlen für die schweiz gold und silber
[Musik]
nun fallen die ersten entscheidungen
auch in der halle
wird auch um jede sekunde jeden
zentimeter gefightet
es zeigt sich schnell die masters sich
die senioren nennen sind eine große
familie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das jüngste mitglied ist der 93-jährige
e-mails aus belgien
[Applaus]
ich deutschland und belgien
ja ja viel und welche das passiert die
800 und 1500 m 200 m 400 kanada
kalifornien action er brasilien der
senioren kleinen vermisst in finnland
eine angehörige besonders gut beste
freundin die legendäre pina gurtner
wir besuchen die 86 jährige in ihrer
wohnung in bern
sie hat sich vom wettkampfsport
zurückgezogen joggt aber noch jeden
morgen um 5 wurde aare entlang
auch sie hat erst spät mit 55 jahren das
erste mal die laufschuhe geschnürt
es war einer der wichtigsten entscheide
im leben der gebürtigen italienerin
ich weiß nicht wie andere frauen
premiere mann zitiert der vor einer
schule eine lichtung nagasaki du
beschuss frau als er mit berufen die in
ägypten und da bin ich einfach froh
wieder zu überzeugen
die kinder zogen mit der frage aber
plötzlich um vorgeschmack bietet mehrere
viele sache ja fahren können erfahrene
mutter bis sagen welche irgendwo landen
wäre mit der sport könne man sie bieten
schon beim ersten wettkampf haben sich
die konkurrentinnen ruth und pina
angefreundet
china wurde zu fuß großen vorbild york
als auch die konkurrenz und den
herrlichen bällen und ab von der
speziell zur vermissten schaffte vom
marathon gewonnen
ich will das aber mal
sie hat sich ihren traum erfüllt und
helfenstein die spätberufene holten
finnland goldmedaille um goldmedaille
über 400 meter stellt sie gar einen
neuen weltrekord auf noch nie lief eine
über 80-jährige frau so schnell doch ein
wettkampf steht noch aus der 60 meter
finale
das große ziel dafür hat sie die letzten
monate täglich trainiert und doch ist
sie nervös
ich habe noch probleme
die größte konkurrentin ist sie seien so
ban
[Musik]
dann stehen sie bereit für den alles
entscheidenden lauf auf bahn zwei ganz
rechts außen gut helfenstein die
engländerin mary xi und holger kurth l
co aus kanada laufen in der kategorie
der über 90-jährigen bahn fünf dann die
selbstbewusste finnin sanna support und
linksaußen mit außenseiter chancen
wieder frei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
was ist für dich lernen und
es sollte die stadt richtig schnell
mit freudigen
[Musik]
mut helfen steigen 80 jahre alt
siebenfache weltmeisterin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so endet denn diese geschichte mit
der tröstlichen erkenntnis dass es nie
zu spät ist sich neuen herausforderungen
zu stellen
auch im alter nicht gut brennt weiter
[Musik]